Leonardo DiCaprio attended the premiere
and by the end his date was too old for
him Ricky Gervais is open the 2020
Golden Globes with a wild monologue but
the night was also filled with so many
other memorable moments I also have to
thank my partner in crime LDC he's an
all-star he's a gent and I wouldn't be
here without you man I thank you the
speeches from the stars were the best
like Brad Pitt who revealed his nickname
for Leonardo DiCaprio when he won for
his supporting role in Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood he also made a Titanic joke
still I would have shared the raft and
x-gen Aniston looked on supportively the
whole time
the world the Internet everyone is
waiting they're hoping for this moment
where you and Jennifer run into each
other so they can take their picture run
into Jen she's a good friend Tom Hanks
got emotional accepting the Cecil B
deMille Award a man is a mattis bless
what the family sitting down front like
that
Joaquin Phoenix also got a little choked
up as he thanked fiance Rooney Mara
after winning Best Actor for his role in
Joker Rooney um the female winners had
fierce political messages we have to
vote in 2020 and plead for everyone we
know to vote and when it is time to vote
please do so in your own self-interest
it's what men have been doing for years
other stars spread awareness about the
Australian wildfires Australia I love
you my heart goes out to everyone who is
suffering in Australia all the animals
that we've lost when one country faces a
climate disaster we all face a climate
disasters hey is everything okay because
I know that your house was threatened by
the fires yes yes our house is um okay
obviously it's day by day right now
in Australia so but as we said you know
we're so concerned were so worried
we loves our country and so we're just
we're all hoping and praying but we're
in it together things got a little weird
a few times throughout like when Ansel
Elgort took the stage to announce Best
Original Song in a motion picture here
are the nominees for Best Original
and when Elton John won that category if
he almost took a tumble we also loved
all the mini reunions and cute
friendships we saw Reese Witherspoon and
Joaquin Phoenix who started walk the
line together Reese also posed with her
big little lies co-star shailene woodley
and legends with legends aka Meryl
Streep and Helen Mirren and how cute is
this pic Taylor Swift and Aquafina
it was also a big night for fleabag and
succession I'd like to also thank Abama
for putting us on his list he's always
been on mine do we owe this all to Obama
is pretty cool when he says you're one
of his favorite show yes fleabag took
home the award for best comedy or
musical while Phoebe Waller bridge also
won Best Actress how good is the party
tonight going to be what now succession
won Best Drama while Brian Cox took home
an acting prize it's one hell of a party
tonight isn't it it's a really good
party do you renegotiate tomorrow or do
you give them a like a week before you
renegotiate
[Music]